we turn now to the impending supreme
court nomination
we start with a little background on aim
judge amy coney barrett
she's the mother of seven including two
adopted children
from the country of haiti she is a
practicing catholic
just like joe biden and nancy pelosi she
has embarked on a successful
and impressive career as an attorney as
a professor
and as a judge if confirmed she will be
the youngest person on the bench
she will be the fifth women woman ever
to serve on the u.s supreme court
judge barrett is known as a textualist
one who values the meaning of the u.s
constitution
that would include things like the first
and second amendment she has argued in
favor of gun rights
as is in the constitution including for
those who have been convicted of
nonviolent crimes
she is also a strong defender of due
process
and the presumption of innocence on the
issue of abortion in spite of the lies
the left will tell you judge barrett
has been described as personally
pro-life
but has expressed doubts that roe v wade
will ever be overturned
again she is an original she believes in
precedent and she has said so
she believes in co-equal branches of
government she believes in the concept
the separation of powers
she is not an activist jurist she is not
trying to write or recreate settle law
and she will not legislate from the
bench and despite what you will hear
which will be a lot of lies predictably
from democrats judge barrett has never
directly ruled on any abortion case she
did once
argue in favor of judges recusing
themselves for
conscience issues or religious reasons
surrounding
important cases like the death penalty
in other words
issues of conscience i thought that
mattered to people on the left
judge barrett is extraordinarily well
qualified she is extremely smart
educated with a lot of experience
extremely
impressive individual professional on
every level
she is a constitutionalist and that
means the left will
and is already vilifying her now they
want you to believe and they will want
you to believe she's an extremist
monster
monster who is unfit to serve they will
lie they will smear they will slander
that is who they are that is what they
do
yahoo news they published an article it
reads quote
this is amy coney barrett the potential
rbg replacement who hates your uterus
that's a lie reuters openly wondered if
this was the beginning of the
handmaid's tale quote u.s supreme court
candidate's religious community under
scrutiny and reuters was only one of
many
outlets that attempted to use the
dystopian
handmaid's tale to smear barrett's
catholic faith does anyone question joe
biden's faith
no anyone question nancy pelosi's faith
no and by the way
nor should they nor should anyone that
is between them
their conscience their church and their
personal belief in god
it's nobody's business it happens to be
a fact that they
are at odds with quote church doctrine
on many issues
that's none of our business now still
newsweek published the basis
attack against justice or judge barrett
uh
so did several other so-called news
organizations
the attacks on judge barrett's character
didn't stop there
this is the beginning of well a month
from hell for her and her family take a
look
so i think the stakes of this nomination
are very clear if if it is in fact
barrett
she is someone who will implement donald
trump's
agenda across the board
forty-eight-year-old barrett is a mother
of seven who has won over religious
conservatives for having anti-abortion
views
but in some ways she would be the polar
opposite of ruth bader ginsburg because
she's a a pretty clear opponent of
abortion
and and that may be a key point for the
president he'll want to uh nominate
somebody who
is uh determined to overturn roe v wade
there's
civil rights and labor union rights and
gay rights and women's rights the right
to choose roe v wade could be undone
by a court this extreme no she said she
believes the precedent